so we all know
that gamestop was in the headlines
gamestop was the game company people
used to buy games there they felt
nostalgic about it they liked it well
who felt nostalgic about it
well a bunch of guys are on reddit using
guys and gals
they're on reddit that we're using
reddit the way it was intended to
exchange information and
chat with each other rebut each other
you know
yell at each other and do all that and
there was a little group on reddit
called the subreddit
wall street bets and they talked about
what things they wanted to invest in
what they wanted to do
and when they discovered that gamestop
had
huge headphones with giant shorts on it
they wanted to take it to those hedge
funds uh-oh
so they said wait what if we all got
together we're buying at the same time
and we buy the stock and make the stock
price goes up because the hedge funds
were betting that the price would go
down
every time it goes up a certain amount
the hedge fund either has to buy more
stock
to do what's called covering or they
have to put money into their account in
other words just pump
hundreds of millions of dollars in to
cover the difference because they're
betting it to go down this way
but it's going this way so that gap
there is a loss if you're in a
short betting it'll go down position
so they had this planned out what if we
could do it well what happened was
that's exactly what happened
but did they realize how big it would be
that it ended up being
a short squeeze where the short where
the stock goes up
and the shorts are like no don't go up
that's called a short squeeze
it's also called crap in your pants if
you're
a hedge fund guy and you get a couple
billion dollars out there
hi me again brooker at the biz doc
research center
today's case study is brought to you by
depends
whether you're older and starting to
leak or your three
billion dollar short is making you freak
depends has you covered now let's get
back to the case study
and so while the hedge funds guys
started running for their diapers
you had havoc breaking up on the market
and when all of this got added up if you
added up all the losses and everything
as this stock kept going up and up and
up and up past 200 past
300 there was only one word for what was
going on with the hedge funds and it was
damn
they lost nearly 20 billion dollars
this year in the calamity that was here
and then robin hood stopped the trading
at this point people were like wait
we are crushing these guys why are you
stopping the trading
and robin hood said i can't let you
trade anymore i can't let you do that
there's reasons for it all this anger
went at robin hood
you know you had elizabeth warren you
had in washington d.c
saying investigation regulation you had
ted cruz
and aoc investigation regulation
jumping into the mix here here's what
happened and i believe this to be the
truth
first truth is robin hood had been fined
twice and the second one 65 million
hadn't happened that long ago
so there was people with robin hood
accounts that were saying yeah i'm with
robin hood zero dollar trades you know
i don't want to have a brokerage account
any of the any of the big guys or i
don't want to give my money to the man
but there was something going on here
and then when the trading stopped
people said well wait a minute maybe
they're not so good maybe they've sold
out to the man
you know did somebody pick up the phone
and call them and tell them to stop
you know what's going on here well one
of the things that
if you're like robin hood and you're
trading stocks
there's what's called the settlement
period the settlement period is from
where you trade
and where it gets paid for and the trade
is settled there's a window for those
settlement periods that according to
everything i've read
is approximately two days two trading
days
so if you trade on monday it might not
settle exactly until
wednesday in those two-day period the
account people in this case robin hood
have to have enough money in reserve
to cover the value of those trades now i
may be oversimplifying this and
if you want to explain it better leave a
comment down below with the technical
explanation but i'm trying to make it
very simple
so robinhood based on the volume of its
trades
has an obligation a legal obligation a
regulation
to keep a certain amount of money in
reserve or
have that money in reserve to to cover
that settlement
well what do you think happen when the
number of trades
and the dollar volume of the trades goes
up
what do i mean by dollar volume well
dollar volume is if you buy 10
shares for ten dollars that's a hundred
dollars the dollar volume generated by
the trade is a hundred dollars
but if you have ten shares it's at three
hundred
now the dollar volume is three thousand
dollars so the size
of the lump of money that has to be kept
here
to make this two day settlement period
keeps growing
well gamestop is going up all those guys
on wall street bets are egging each
other on
we're crushing the hedge funds they're
losing their butt this is fantastic
well at some point the amount of money
that robin hood
had in its reserve accounts or as the
accounts are
called and kept to cover the settlement
it blew right through that it would be
like you're buying drinks at your
brother's bachelor party and you run out
of space on your visa
everybody stops drinking that's it
unless somebody else wants to use her
credit card
well that's somebody else robin hood
called and got an emergency
one billion dollar loan
on the 29th on friday and then trade
resumed
but to keep it from blowing through the
top again
then they did something which isn't
necessarily in the regulations
they put a cap of one share of certain
companies
well that really infuriated people more
i have no opinion on that
i'm just pointing out that there was a
very real technical requirement
that did hit robin hood and they did go
out and get a billion dollars
to cover this giant settlement period
balance that they had to keep well then
on the 1st of february they went out and
they raised another 2.4 billion
it certainly looked to me by the way
when you add that up
with all the money that i discussed in
the first case study and all the money
they've raised here
they have now raised a grand total of
5.6
billion dollars total fund raise
to date that's a big old number but now
you can see i'm not defending robin hood
i'm not defending limiting you to one
share to buy
but i am pointing out that part of this
there is a very real technical reason
that it makes sense and this is what
robin hood ceo came out and said
and i'll tell you i believe him when he
goes out and says
that there is a technical requirement
and they had to make it the reason is
he's been fined twice and he is
holding brokerage accounts that offer
trading i don't believe he's going to go
out
after being fined twice and tell a
whopper of a lie
on that issue i believe it was that
issue all the rest of the restrictions
the slow growth and everything else he
put on there that impacted a lot of good
people
that had a robin hood account and wanted
to trade hey i don't comment on that
maybe they deserve the slap they were
getting for that
now as i just said i don't really want
to comment on all the conspiracy
theories did this happen did that happen
do they have friends on wall street that
told them to stop the trading i like to
look at the facts
back into them when i'm doing case
studies and see is there smoke
should there be a fire or if there is
smoke there definitely was a fire i like
to back into it that way
before i make assumptions when i build
the case studies and i got one thing to
say here
hedge fund guys lost 20 billion dollars
and i saw
one article that claimed 40 billion
dollars
in the month of january just on
robinhood
that's a lot of money and so if you're
saying the conspiracy
the reason robin hood stopped trading
was because a phone call was made from a
big wig in wall street or washington or
silicon valley or google that had
invested them before
and told them to stop the trading
somebody interfered
all i got to say is if i'm the hedge
fund guys that have lost 13 or
20 or 40 billion dollars and somebody
made a phone call to do it
keep in mind i lost 13 or 20 or 40
billion dollars and you're pretty damn
late to save my ass
thanks for watching the short clip if
you like that and like to see the whole
episode
you can find it right here and for even
more
subscribe to this channel right here
[Music]
you